hey Rob handlery here with a gamespot  news update on titanfall for the xbox  one Xbox Live has been struggling to get  players in two matches on titanfall a  second issue was also preventing some  xbox live users on the Xbox one from  being able to sign in all together  microsoft said it was investigating the  problems xbox live for Xbox 360 was not  affected in the case of titanfall  respawn engineer john shirring said in  an interview yesterday with in gadget  that any server issues that occur for  the new game are on Microsoft to fix  this is because the game relies so  heavily upon Microsoft's cloud servers  titanfall requires internet connection  to play meaning every copy of the game  in the wild is tapping into the network  for more on time falls check out  GameSpot's review